[Music]
all right holding up pretty good
yeah I'll tell you having my family here
is uh I wouldn't want to have anybody
else here but my mom and dad my family
my friends and it's just good to have
them here in to know that they're there
with me and that they're gonna be
rooting for me and that they're proud of
me so it feels good I look at her and I
think about her when she was a baby when
she was born you know all that kinda get
a whole lot of things go through my mind
of course you know being a mother and
that's where I see more than anything
else yeah and I still see her as my
little girl with the long braids down
yeah she's always gonna be my baby
I brought my handkerchief but I left it
in the room I think she tries not to
appeal it comes in it goes you know it's
like going like butterflies you know
what's that I got a little while when it
leaves you don't think about it and if
you never not nervous watch out because
things are never gonna go right if
you're not there it's a bad omen when
you're not nervous oh my goodness well
first I must give thanks to God and
makes it all possible for me
to my mommy and daddy two most important
people in my life do you feel like
Cinderella got the grams
yeah yeah feels great Whitney obviously
you knew a lot of people we're gonna
have their eyes on you tonight how did
you pick what you were gonna wear tell
us about your dress I saw I liked and I
bought it yeah how is all this
acceptance and success and love changed
you over the years it really hasn't you
know I've just gotten busier much busier
oh I can't tell you how proud I am of
her I was just so thrilled it was very
very exciting I knew it was me because
Dionne said that's my new I feel great